comment ça va aujourd'hui regardez alors
aujourd'hui on est à l'aise légasse à
l'aise le diable pour regarder quoi pour
parler d'un salon qui s'appelle rima
frimas et écrit sur mon badge l'âge
parce que le voyez bien patron approché
alors harry mars c'est un salon qui va
venir parler d'innovation qui va venir
parler de tech en règle générale qui va
venir parler de tout apport trop du côté
d'amazon à savoir c'est plutôt à w s
organisera donc c'est amazon web
services isme parler de claude on va
parler de machine learning on va parler
d'intelligence artificielle et la madone
a profité pour nous présenter leur petit
robot
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
petit robot qui s'appelle astro alors
astro était présentée l'année dernière
sur le web un concept intéressant et là
il est arrivé enfin taureau en tout cas
on peut le voir alors astro c'est pas du
tout un produit qui va être fait pour
tout le monde tout de suite c'est un
produit qui est uniquement testé sur le
marché américain j'annonce le tarif se
sont parés pas déconner ça me paraît
bien 999 dollars alors qu'est ce que tu
as trop bien faire et bien astro
s'inscrit dans ces petit robot qu'on
vient voir pour vous y retrouver qui
sont des robots compagnons attention on
n'est pas dans la robotique humanoïde
l'idée si c'est pas d'avoir un robot qui
va marcher qui alors des baraques à
faire des choses pour vous non pas du
tout il est l'idée savoir je dirais
comme un écho chaussures ou avec une
alexa qu'à venir vous suivrez vous
parler c'est plus solide et avec un côté
un petit peu sympathique alors on voit
que ça tarn est de démocratiser tout
doucement tu commences à te reprendre un
peu la mayonnaise au niveau de la
robotique parce que ça fait peur à pas
mal de gens je déjà montré des robots
avec d'étranges vraiment très humanoïde
qui faisait pas le coup il perd peur on
a un peu de mal à se projeter et
toujours un côté un peu whaou qu'est ce
que c'est que ce truc là le petit robot
astro franchement vous fait pas peur si
vous vous sentez pas à l'aise voulu
mettre un coup de pied sans moi c'est
terminé je crois que ne le fait pas
alors est-ce que ce repos va arriver en
france on ne sait pas pour l'instant les
tester sur le marché américain
arrivera-t-il peut-être je pense que oui
je pense que là il est est ce qu'ils
vont mettre en place ils vont à corriger
certaines choses à une fois qu'il sera
complètement fonctionner avec un
déploiement au niveau de la langue
également dans tous les pays dont on
pourrait retrouver en france à arras
trop s'il a pas mal de petites choses
astro déjà il faut vraiment l'imaginé
comme un écho chaussée hier c'est les
enceintes intelligente d'aller d'amazon
avec sa souris clairement c'est ça alors
pour autant il ya 1 n'aura pas c'est pas
aller que ça qui va venir vous suivre
bien qu'on retrouve vraiment dû alexa à
l'intérieur c'est à dire pouvait émettre
amazon musique pour m prague vidéo vous
avez toutes les questions vous posez
alex à mettre un timer quelle heure
est-il lui poser des questions sur des
lieux vous voulez visiter avec toute
l'intelligence qu'on trouve à alexa
derrière c'est à dire des recherches
multimodal un côté conversationnel
également bref tout ce qui fait le
charme d'alexa aujourd'hui ça c'est ce
qu'on avait retrouvé un petit peu dans
ce côté là le grand package si vous
utilisez alexa vous serez pas perdu et
castro maintenant ils sont venus lui
apporter des fonctionnalités un peu à
part puisqu'on a un petit robot qui se
déplacent autant venir en profiter alors
première chose qu'ils ont glissé une
petite caméra télescope qui va venir
petit très très grand fait un grand
périscope spa télescope d'un périscope
qui ressort d'astro et qui montre
jusqu'à une taille humaine l'idée en
fait c'est quoi c'est comme astro est
tout petit et bien il ya une petite
caméra intégrée mais vous allez avoir
une vision un peu comme mon petit chien
c'est à dire du sol nous ce qu'on veut
c'est pouvoir voir ce qui se passe au
dessus d'un meuble pour faire aussi un
peu de surveillance alors obtenu à le
faire à castro très facilement c'est à
dire comment ça se passe et bien voulu
poser une question par exemple vous êtes
loin vous êtes j'en sais rien au travail
astro montre noah la porte de la baie
vitrée je ne sais rien des vitres rayent
montre moi le salon où il va et douvres
le périscope ils regardent vous voyez ce
qui se passe donc à côté un peu
rassurant à ce qu'on va vous servir en
rond comme une caméra de surveillance à
la maison qui va venir se balader alors
qu'ils se baladent oui non si vous avez
des étages astro et sur roulettes elle
ne s'est pas monter les stages hormis ce
n'est pas le but donc vous le mettez en
bas si vous avez un bac dans la thèse
principale à faire le job ça c'est quand
même assez pratique pour l'utiliser
correctement il faut bien évidemment
venir paramétrer ses pièces de la même
manière que vous le ferez avec un
aspirateur robot vous lasser le salon
c'est ça c'est ça vous lui apprenez tout
vous voulez même scanner votre visage
pour qu'il vous connaissent lorsqu'elle
est votre visage et également ceux des
membres de votre famille ce qui fait que
lorsque audit maintien astro va par
exemple dire un message à jos à rien -
elliott en ce qui me concerne up votre
obédience il va lui délivrer un message
et en plus y'a un truc qui est assez
marrant ce qu'à l'arrière vous avez un
petit coffre alors vous pouvez mettre
soit de petits porte gobelets soit vous
l'enlevez c'est une folle espèce de
grand coffre met un grand objet vous le
mettez dans tien an men à elliott sont
au capital et partie héliose prend le
coca et tout se passe bien et qu'aucun
quota c est rigolo c'est le petit usage
pour vient porter avec un petit robot
sur ou comme ça qui va directement bon
pourquoi pas hisser à comme je vous le
disais pour tout ce qui va être sous
surveillance de la maison si un souci
vous enverra lui derrière t il ya même
une vision nuit donc si vous êtes parti
que vous êtes en vacances je ne sais où
lui vaut la nuit ça c'est bien aussi et
s'il repère qui a eu un problème une
intrusion à brides verts eelv à venir
déclenché une alarme ça va vous pétez un
peu les oreilles mais ça pourra faire
fut en tout cas probablement le mauvaise
personne l'assaillant qui sera chez vous
dans cette banale ou déjà fait pas mal
de petites choses et si vous l'avez plus
loin avec de la patrouille automatique
et bien vous pourrez prendre un
abonnement avec ring c'est la société
des caméras de surveillance d'amazon
avec un embout s'appelle ring rotec trop
qui aura la foule complète vous aurez
toutes les manières surveiller les
alertes le csa bref on convoque en plus
d'acheter le produit il vous pouvez
acheter du service pour coter
surveillance c'est pas inclus avec entre
tous qui est aussi intéressant pour la
maison vous avez un capteur de monoxyde
d'azoté un capteur de fumée s'il se
balader qui captent à un moment mais il
ya un petit souci lui va venir l'activer
vous informez donc je trouve que de ce
côté là aussi il ya un côté vraiment
rassurant et puis surtout c'est l'idée
de venir ok je pense qu amazon s'est dit
on veut faire un petit robot qu'est ce
qu'on peut apporter comme ça et ça peut
venir a ajouté vous vraiment qu'ils
encensent et que les gens viennent
d'acheter à la maison parce que c'est
juste un petit robot histoire de se
marrer bon ok c'est bien mais c'est pas
sa caméra peut changer l'histoire si
vous lui demandez de vous suivre par
exemple tu y as trop bien que moi dans
le salon pour lui va faire une action en
particulier se trouve un boost pour que
c'est pareil tout à la commande vocale
que ça c'est marrant alors je t'ai vu
faire je les ai vus se déplacer et c'est
extrêmement bluffant moi je suis
habituée aux robots aspirateurs qui se
déplacent mais à leur rythme le temps
ils sont pas énervés lui c'est une vrai
petite bombe il va hyper vite donc vous
vous dites que pour aller délivrer un
message pour amener quelque chose vous
suivre d'une pièce à l'autre ça va ça
mon bar quand même alors en fait tu as
trop ce que vous avez sur le dessus
c'est un petit écran qui orientable qui
va venir bouger parce que forcément
comme il est en bas il faut pouvoir voir
ce qui se passe en a donné un côté un
peu sympa avec des yeux c'est vrai que
sinon vous avez juste un écran sans un
côté un peu humain qui vient rassurer je
pense que ça ferait flipper plus d'un an
et c'est aussi tout ça qui est vachement
impasse parce que si vous voulez la
robotique dont nous ça fait un peu
flipper il faut avoir un côté sympa côté
francilien côté un peu joué jouets pour
adultes mais qui ira aussi avec un
enfant parce que vous avez tous les
services d'amazon alexa derrière poires
des services dédiés aux enfants il a
coûté peut venir danser avec vous si
vous voulez faire danser votre enfant
vous amuser voilà c'est très fort ceci
un truc est très américain il faut avoir
du fun à côté fun pour que ça fonctionne
bon ok why not il ya un autre usage qui
était montré et que ton assez
intéressant c'est pour les personnes
âgées à savoir qu'ils vont pouvoir
effectivement les aider les assister et
alerter s'il ya un souci notamment la
détection de chute taxi votre parent par
exemple à astro à la maison et qu'il
tombe bien pouvoir vous en alerte et
appeler les secours qu'elles vous
appelez-vous alors pas pu tester la
fonctionnalité on voit un petit plus qui
s'annonce de ce côté là mais c'est
plutôt intéressant et voyez ça va dans
le sens de l'histoire puisque font les
fabricants chante otamment apple avec la
détection de chute qu'on a sur l'apple
watch eh bien ça peut venir en
complément alors pour autant est-ce que
vous allez mettre en appelant un autre
papa votre papier nicolas nahas 3 la
maison je sais pas d'autant plus qu'il
faut quand même accepté d'avoir un petit
robot à la maison mais bon en tout cas
je trouve ça a plutôt rassurant d'une
pour des personnes âgées mais également
pour la famille qui se dit ok est ce qui
va bien il n'a pas répondu au téléphone
qu'est-ce qui se passe concert qui a
troqué la honte ou éventuellement
l'envoyer peut-être qu'on puisse
collecter vos raquettes la caméra
intérieure il ya un côté un peu intrusif
parce que si vous êtes les enfants et
que vous envoyez astro venir voir ce qui
se passe chez vos parents que la caméra
vers là vous êtes quand même vraiment la
vie privée plus plus plus salée pendant
la relation qu'on entretient avec sa
dépense peut vous donner comme accès
alors ça c'est des choses avoir affiné
mais bon en tout cas l'idée elle est là
c'est à dire venir développer le service
on voit que c'est pour les enfants pour
la famille mais également pour les
personnes âgées avec toutes ces
personnes amazon s'assure de venir
toucher un peu tout le monde en fait
alors après ce que c'est un peu la
limite du truc en disant on vient
toucher tout le monde est ce qu'on fait
quand tous pas perçoit également ça je
sais pas mais une fois de plus je vous
dis vous robot on n'est pas encore en
france je pense qu'ils testent le marché
américain et qu'on verra plus tard si la
richesse alors qu'elles sont un peu les
limites de ce roman à la limite c'est
qu'on n'est pas dans un robot humanoïde
c'est à dire pas de bras pas de jambes
dont quelque chose qu'il ne fera pas
pour vous il n'est pas en capacité
monter dans les étages pour venir vous
suivre la hausse n'est pas en capacité
descendre les escaliers pour autant il a
des capteurs pour les élections de chute
pas sûr que la caisse casse pas la
gueule tout simplement ça c'est bien
autant il a un petit porte gobelets à
l'arrière mais n'a pas la capacité
d'attraper des objets csa quelqu'un qui
veuille aller prendre de les poser dans
et de l'envoyer voulait livrer si c'est
dans une maison vous voulez que vous
êtes capable de prendre vos jambes et de
faire de maître quand même fait mon bon
j'ai goûté un peu marketing reçoit rien
je suis dans la cuisine je vous donnais
une canette ayotte alors soit ils se
lèvent les faits se bougent le cul comme
on pourrait dire et il verra chez sa
canette soit bon il vraiment hyper
captivé dans un dessin animé je prends
je lui en même parce que chaque fois pas
hyper cool est ce que pour autant je
vais appeler as3 java pour le faire
bonsoir et à se trouver bien la feci
déjà le temps que je l'appelle j'ai les
jambes des tombeaux royaux ces images là
il faudra vraiment voir ça tient la
route dans le temps l'autre sujet qui
est quand même extrêmement fort c'est
tout ce qui va être donnée personnelle
sécurité et tout le driver sied à la
maison alors ce que nous dit ici amazon
c'est qu'en fait il n'y a absolument
aucun risque que 2 puis le début son
travail et avec énormément de couches de
protection mais on sait très bien qu'à
un moment ou un autre les meilleurs
pirates réussir ont interprété un peu le
système alors ça veut pas dire qu'ils
vont le faire c'est à dire on a intérêt
à me regarder ce qui se passe chez vous
et même si on y arrive on au delà des
cambrioleurs qui veulent venir repérer
les lieux faute at il déjà qu'ils
sachent que vous ayez un astro et qu'ils
aient la capacité biologique devenir ni
piraté c'est quand même pas mal de
barrières déjà mais bon on peut se poser
la question des données personnelles
déjà par rapport à des tirs extérieurs
mais également par rapport à ma zone
parce que amazon qui ont déjà beaucoup
de choses de vous au travers de toutes
les informations que lui font 10 et
alexa mail en plus de ça ils connaissent
votre maison ils connaissent toutes vos
habitudes donc non au progrès on peut
venir se dire qu'est ce qu'ils vont
venir faire je me dis que sur le marché
européen on est quand même beaucoup plus
protégés après amazon vous dit quelque
chose qui seront dans l'euro certaines
choses qui seront dans le cloud qu'est
ce qu'ils vont faire qu'est ce qu'ils
peuvent en faire quel est le risque
profond derrière je ne sais pas en tout
cas ça soit fermé pas mal de questions
tout en sachant qu amazon nous a dit que
pour venir sapere directement astro il
faut que vous soyez à côté avec vos
smartphones courte distance donc on
imagine que on peut pas dire ça paierait
à 15 mètres bref si c'est vraiment ce
qui rassure mais en tout cas il faut le
savoir et doit pas durement tech alors
j'ai quelques petites infos si c'est un
robot qui fait un peu moins de 10 kg 9
kg 35 pour être très précis sa charge
tout seul en 45 minutes vous vite astro
d'un votre charge et ils valent millions
il se recharge et c'est parti pour 45
minutes d'attenté pourra retrouver à
l'avancé un écran hd cdu 10,1 pouces
1280 par 800 pixels pas besoin de plus
très honnêtement et la caméra qui va
sortir c'est une caméra de 5 mégapixels
c'est du 1080p avec un angle de vision
de 130 degrés et après c'est du
périscope 1 et comme un astre on peut se
balader bien trop bien voir un peu ce
qui se passe de tout les côtés mais tout
ça pas mal aussi vous voyez c'est
marrant de voir comment est ce qu amazon
il dû bosser sur ce petit robot en fait
la robotique bosse dessus depuis des
années avec tous les robots qui vont
développer pour leur propre aux
entrepôts mais là il arrive vraiment
dans la robotique domestique directement
chez vous alors soyez tranquilles les
robots aujourd'hui ce sont pas nos
ennemis ne fera que ça le sera un jour
pour autant tous côtés fantasmé avec les
films qu'on a pu voir dans les années
80-90 retrouve encore aujourd'hui je ne
pense pas ce qu'on voit c'est que
vraiment amazon c'est assez
impressionnant ce qu'ils viennent faire
on a vu en assistant vocal on a
effectivement les échos show ont la cote
en assurant une espèce des cochons à
roulettes quelle est la prochaine étape
pour que amazon vient de vous aider
davantage dans votre vie quotidienne je
sais pas en tout cas c'est une v12 leur
robot c'est un premier robot j'imagine
voulons d'autres dans les tuyaux de
quelle manière pour l'instant à priori
ne semble pas se positionner sur du
robot humanoïde avec des bras et des
jambes mais sait-on jamais peut-être un
jour et j'ai vu me confond intéressante
tout à l'heure à quelqu'un qui disait
aujourd'hui on en est vraiment aux
balbutiements de tout ce qui est
robotique il faut imaginer que on en est
la robotique aujourd'hui là on en est et
dans l'informatique dans les années 50
60 des espèces de grandes pièces avec un
ordinateur pour faire afficher à grand
chose qu'on en fait donc c'est vraiment
le tout début l'histoire j'imagine qu'il
faudra quelques bonnes années pour que
les robots vienne partout chez nous des
robots humanoïdes en tout cas parce que
les robots comme ça il y en a
quelques-uns mais je ne pense pas que le
niveau d'adoption d'acceptation une
population globale soit encore vraiment
l'avoir dit mme avouait ce qu'un robot
comme astro pourrez vous tentez ce que
pour ce gadget qu'est ce que vous en
feriez au delà du fait de se dire ah bah
ok il peut venir danser peut me donner
la météo et à me donner la météo en
suivant il peut emmener une canette à
monfils il peut surveiller papa ou
papier au delà de ça qu'est ce qui va
venir faire sa stroë qu'est ce que vous
vous en pensez alors dites moi si vous
voyez des usages en particulier autres
que ceux que j'ai dessiné tout de suite
et ce que vous explique et puis surtout
est ce que une fois castro sera la halle
et 999 dollars on peut l'imaginer à un
petit 1500 euros chez nous est ce que
vous seriez prêt à débourser 1500 euros
pour ce qui est aujourd'hui un gadget en
tout cas moi je trouve ça hyper
intéressant je suis fan de tête donc
plus que l'idée est là sauf que les
découle maintenant voilà prend du temps
doucement chose arrive donc affaire à
suivre voilà j'embrasse à très vite pour
le soigner
[Musique]